Every one of you here tonight, and watching at home,
has a brain inside your head.
Every brain is important.
Every brain is unique. But all brains have
the same
basic machinery working.
So how does the brain work?
Well, to help me answer these questions,
I've invited along another brain scientist
Professor Vince Walsh from University
College London so give a big round of applause to Vince.
So Vince, you've brought along a special
machine that
influences the brain which we're gonna see
in action in a moment. But before we do so,
let's start with a very simple demonstration.
Do you know the nursery rhyme
Baa baa black sheep?
I think so.
Could you give us maybe the first line?
Baa baa black sheep have you any wool?
That's very good, it's reassuring to know
that professors still know their nursery rhymes.
Okay, I'm gonna get you to repeat that
but this time
I'm going to stimulate this part of your
brain with your machine
Start please
Baa baa bla jaa beee yeea byee
[laughter]
Would you like me to do some more
disruption of Vince's brain?
Yes
Okay Vince I'm sorry but we're going to
put you through some more.
Okay so what else should we try?
How about some some motor control?
We could do that, we could try left and right-handed.
Can we try just affecting your right
hand would that be okay?
I'm going to take a magnet now it's
fully charged up again
I'll touch my nose a few times
Okay, let's see how accurate you are
when I place it up here.
Is that the correct area?
Yes umm
Now Vince, tell us what that feels like
It's actually quite painless but
I've lost control of my muscles
I've lost control of my
ability to
locate my a hand in space.
It's a very very weird sensation.
Can we do one last example?
Can you clap for us?
I'll stick the magnet here, are you ready?
Start clapping please.
[Laughter]
I think we've put you through enough Vince.